Es wird eine gigantische Planetenmaschine:
das Dresdyn-Experiment. Denn hier wird nichts
Geringeres als das Magnetfeld der Erde nachgebaut.
Der absolute Wahnsinn! Und vielleicht gibt
sie uns sogar Hinweise darauf, ob und wann
sich das Magnetfeld demnächst möglicherweise
umpolt - und welche fatalen Folgen für das
Leben auf der Erde dieses Ereignis mit sich
bringen würde...Wir freuen uns, dieses Thema
von P.M. mit exklusivem Material aus dem aktuellen
Heft übernehmen zu können. In Zusammenarbeit
mit der Zeitschrift gibt es übrigens auch
noch ein Hammer-Gewinnspiel, bei dem ihr ein
BRESSER Messier Teleskop gewinnen könnt.
Also, los geht‘s.
Herzlich willkommen und ein riesen Dank an
P.M.
Eine Zeitschrift, bei der die gleiche Begeisterung
für Wissenschaft vorherrscht, wie bei uns.
Und die genauso viel Wert auf gute Recherche,
Wahrheit und Fakten legt. Für die Ungeduldigen
ist der Link zum Gewinnspiel übrigens in
der Infobox. Wenn man sich da weiterklickt,
kommt man auch zu den genauen Teilnahmebedingungen
Es handelt sich um eine echte “Höllen-Maschine”
am Rande des technisch Machbaren. Die Rede
ist vom “Dresdyn”-Projekt - weltweit wohl
das ehrgeizigste Experiment zur Erforschung
des Erdmagnetfeldes. Am Helmholtz-Zentrum
in Dresden-Rossendorf entsteht mitten im Wald
die Anlage namens “Dresdyn”. Das steht
für “Dresdner Natrium-Anlage für Dynamo-
und Thermohydraulikforschung”. Ab 2022 soll
hier ein künstliches Mini-Erdmagnetfeld erschaffen
werden! Damit will die Wissenschaft endlich
den vielen mysteriösen Rätseln rund um diesen
- wirklich so bedeutenden - Schutzschirm der
Erde auf die Schliche kommen. Doch noch wird
das Experiment aufgebaut. Wer die Forschungshalle
betritt, steht vor einer inneren Halle mit
schweren Betonwänden. Die Forschenden nennen
sie das “Containment” – ein Begriff,
der man sonst für die innerste Sicherheitshülle
von Kernkraftwerken nutzt. Und das ist tatsächlich
passend, denn dieses Containment ist mit dem
in einem Atomkraftwerk vergleichbar: Die Anlage
ist ein absoluter Gigant am Rande des technisch
Machbaren. Im Zentrum des Containments steht
ein Sockel, auf gewaltigen Beinen aus Beton.
Darauf liegt eine drehbare Plattform, auf
ihr thront ein stählerner Koloss mit vier
Armen. Er soll bald das Herzstück der Anlage
tragen. Die Rede ist von einem tonnenschweren,
zylindrischen Tank, der nicht nur zwei Meter
hoch ist, sondern auch einen Durchmesser von
zwei Metern hat. Der Behälter soll unseren
Erdkern simulieren. Also den Ort, der unglaubliche
3000 bis 6000 Kilometer unter unseren Füßen
liegt. Hier entspringt nämlich das Erdmagnetfeld.
Und auch, wenn es uns ständig umgibt, hat
die Wissenschaft es trotz intensiver Forschung
noch nicht vollständig verstanden. Klar ist
nur, dass wir es in unserem Alltag so gut
wie nie bemerken. Dabei ist es super wichtig
für uns, denn es schirmt unseren Planeten
vor Gefahren ab. Unter anderem schützt es
uns vor den elektrisch geladenen Teilchen,
die bei Sonnenstürmen in Massen auf die Erde
prasseln. Das Magnetfeld lenkt sie ab – und
so erreichen sie die Erde im besten Fall erst
gar nicht. Wenn sie über Polregionen in die
Atmosphäre eindringen, entstehen Polarlichter.
Ein wunderschönes buntes Spektakel - und
eine Folge der kosmischen Abwehr. Zudem bietet
uns das Erdmagnetfeld auch vor kosmischen
Geschossen, die aus den Tiefen des Weltalls
herausschießen, Schutz.
Ein großes Glück für uns. Denn wenn die
Teilchen aus dem All ungehindert auf die Erdatmosphäre,
treffen würden, würden sie die Ozonschicht
angreifen. Doch die schützt uns vor der UV-Strahlung
der Sonne. Die Folge wäre nicht nur ein erhöhtes
Hautkrebsrisiko. Möglicherweise hätte das
in der Vergangenheit sogar die Entwicklung
des Lebens auf der Erde bremsen können. Also:
Zum Glück also gibt es das Erdmagnetfeld.
Mit dem Kompass können wir uns an ihm orientieren.
Und auch manche Tiere orientieren sich am
Magnetfeld: Einige Bakterien, Insekten, Reptilien,
Vögel und sogar Säugetiere wie die Fledermaus
haben einen inneren Kompass. Doch bisher weiß
man nicht, welche Organe ihnen diesen siebten
Magnet-Sinn ermöglichen. Auch andere super-spannende
Fragen rund um das Erdmagnetfeld sind noch
unbeantwortet. Wie entsteht es genau?! Warum
schwankt seine Stärke? Und warum polt es
sich alle paar hunderttausend Jahre um?! Fest
steht bislang nur: Das Magnetfeld der Erde
entsteht durch fließende Metalle. Denn bei
rund 4.000 Grad Celsius fließen im äußeren
Erdkern flüssiges Eisen und Nickel um den
festen inneren Erdkern. Das läuft sehr langsam
ab: Konkret fließt das flüssige Eisen mit
rund einem Millimeter pro Sekunde, also rund
dreieinhalb Meter pro Stunde. Doch wie genau
entsteht dabei das Erdmagnetfeld? Dieses mysteriöse
Rätsel soll nun endlich mit Hilfe von Dresdyn
geklärt werden. Unglaubliche acht Tonnen
flüssiges Natrium im Tank nehmen hier die
Rolle der Metalle im Erdkern ein. Damit diesem
Natrium-Tank ein Magnetfeld entspringt, muss
Einiges mit ihm passieren. Weil der Planet
um sich selbst rotiert, wird auch der 33-Tonnen
schwere Tank in Rotation versetzt - vorangetrieben
von einem Elektromotor. Der sechs Kubikmeter
große Behälter lässt sich um 45 bis 90
Grad kippen. Und dann wird endgültig klar,
warum Dresdyn eine Höllenmaschine ist. Denn
der gesamte gut 130 Tonnen schwere Aufbau
steht selbst auf einer drehbaren Plattform!
Und diese dreht sich mit bis zu einer Umdrehung
pro Sekunde. Da wirken wirklich gigantische
Kräfte! Fachleute bezeichnen die resultierende
Bewegung als sogenannte “Präzession”.
Diese ist der Taumelbewegung der Erdachse
im All nachempfunden. Letztere spielt sich
allerdings nicht in Sekunden, sondern über
viele Tausend Jahre ab. Doch das Dresdyn-Experiment
natürlich sehr viel kleiner als die Erde.
Und so muss es sich entsprechend schneller
drehen, um denselben Effekt hervorzurufen.
Der Stahlkoloss hat dabei die Größe eines
Kleinbusses und das Gewicht eines vollen Schiffscontainers.
Dennoch soll es sich wilder drehen es jedes
Karussell es tut. Die Sensoren am Rand des
Rotationsbehälters laufen dann mit rund 250
Kilometern pro Stunde im Kreis. Der Elektromotor
wird eine Fliehkraft erfahren, die dem 15-Fachen
seiner Gewichtskraft entspricht. Auch der
Rotationsbehälter muss viel aushalten: Acht
Tonnen flüssiges Natrium werden aufgrund
der Rotation mit 20 Bar auf die Außenwände
drücken. Außerdem wird der Tank einen Wechseldruck
erfahren, der zehnmal pro Sekunde um acht
Bar schwankt. Wow! Nur so kann das Erdmagnetfeld
realistisch simuliert werden. Denn die Entstehung
des Magnetfeldes der Erde ist ein hochkomplexer
Prozess. Nicht nur die bewegten Massen und
Kräfte sind gewaltig, es gibt auch viele
Effekte, die sich gegenseitig verstärken
oder auslöschen. Selbst Hochleistungsrechner
können das nur ansatzweise berechnen. Zugleich
ist der Prozess sensibel: Wenn nicht alle
Rahmenbedingungen stimmen, entsteht kein stabiles
Magnetfeld. Das ist doch schon fast paradox:
In Experimenten ist es super kompliziert,
solch ein Magnetfeld herzustellen. Die Erde
dagegen bekommt dies zuverlässig hin - und
das seit Jahrmilliarden. Und ohne dieses Magnetfeld
wäre die Erde viel lebensfeindlicher als
mit. Das ist schon verrückt, wie perfekt
hier alles passt, damit Leben existieren kann.
Der Erdmagnetismus gehört mit zu den entscheidenden
Rahmenbedingungen wür die Exuístenz von
uns Menschen. In der Theorie wird der Prozess
beschrieben durch die Magnetohydrodynamik.
Sie erklärt das Verhalten elektrisch leitfähiger
Flüssigkeiten. Und zu denen gehört eben
auch die heiße Mischung aus Eisen und Nickel
im äußeren Erdkern. Dort sorgen zwei Effekte
dafür, dass das flüssige Metall in Bewegung
gerät. Zum einen gibt der Erdkern auch nach
viereinhalb Milliarden Jahren noch Hitze ab
und sorgt für Konvektionsströme: Die heißen
Metalle strömen nach außen, kühlen sich
ab und sinken wieder hinab. Vergleichbar ist
das mit einer Lavalampe. Zum anderen bewirkt
die Drehung der Erde eine starke Corioliskraft,
die alle Bewegungen zur Seite ablenkt. In
der Summe ergeben sich verdrehte Strömungen
im äußeren Erdkern. Es ist wirklich eine
riesige Herausforderung, diesen Effekt zu
erzeugen: Das flüssige Metall muss in schraubenförmige
Bahnen gezwungen werden. Dabei hat das Magnetfeld
die Tendenz, schneller zu zerfallen als es
durch die Strömung induziert wird. In der
Erde treibt die Wärmebewegung den Prozess
an. Doch das lässt sich in Experimenten kaum
nachbilden. Dort muss mechanisch nachgeholfen
werden. Das “Dresdyn”-Forschungsteam probiert
es per Präzession – indem also der Tank
in verschiedene Richtungen zugleich dreht.
Die Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler
haben die komplizierte Mathematik der Magnetohydrodynamik
immer wieder berechnet. Sie sind zuversichtlich,
dass sie die Effekte so nachahmen können.
Spannend dabei ist auch die Beobachtung, dass
sich das Erdmagnetfeld immer wieder mal umpolt.
Dabei ist sogar eine eine gewisse Regelmäßigkeit
zu erkennen. Diese Umpolungen folgen einem
mehrere Hunderttausend Jahre umfassenden Rhythmus,
bei dem sich das Magnetfeld immer wieder abschwächt.
Und wenn das passiert, sind die Auswirkungen
fatal. Denn das Bombardement der geladenen
Teilchen könnte unsere gesamte Zivilisation
bedrohen. Nicht nur die Kommunikationstechnik,
sondern auch die Elektronik und die Stromnetze
auf der Erde könnten durch Sonnenstürme
beschädigt werden. Neben Blackouts gäbe
es wohl dann auch eine Zunahme der Krebserkrankungen.
Die Dresdner Forscherinnen und Forscher aber
sind zuversichtlich, dass in naher Zukunft
keine Polumkehr ansteht. Doch dafür hofft
er umso mehr, sie schon bald im Labor beobachten
zu können.
Apropos Beobachtung: Jetzt gibt es noch dieses
wirklich sensationelle Teleskop zu gewinnen!
Mit einer ganz hervorragenden Optik! Und auch
die Steuerung hat es in sich, denn sie macht
es möglich, in extrem kurzer Zeit Objekte
am Himmel zu finden. Ein absoluter Traum.
Dafür einfach hier klicken. Kleiner Geheimtipp:
Die Chancen zu gewinnen sind ziemlich gut.
Außerdem gibt es obendrauf auch noch zwei
Gratis-Ausgaben des P.M-Magazins - inklusive
der aktuellen Ausgabe.
Darin gibt es noch viel mehr Infos zu dem
super spannenden “Dresdyn-Projekt, aber
natürlich noch viele weitere wichtige Themen
aus der Wissenschaft und Forschung. Zum Beispiel
zu den beiden Außenseitern im Sonnensystem:
Uranus und Neptun, die viele Geheimnisse bergen.
Oder aber, wie Forschungsteams mit erstaunlichen
Tricks die Wundheilung perfektionieren wollen,
um in Zukunft störende Narben schon im Vorfeld
zu verhindern. Richtig spannend aber auch
der Artikel dazu, wie Exoskelette in vielen
Firmen den Menschen die Arbeit erleichtern
und dabei Muskeln und Gelenke schonen.
Ich drücke euch jedenfalls die Daumen. Bis
dann, bleibt dran!